hey everyone this is Kevin from the test
website calm today are gonna be going
over game eight from the 2014 World
Chess Championship between Magnus
Carlsen the reigning champion and Vichy
and on the Challenger we have games 8 9
10 11 and 12 left Vichy and on has to
play the white pieces three more times
Magnus Carlsen - so vision on playing
the white pieces they definitely trying
to get a victory since he is down a
point at Magnus Carlsen so far and again
there's just not many matches left so
he's definitely going for the victory
here Magnus Carlsen with the black
pieces trying to defend you know if he
could get a win that would pretty much I
think seal the deal but all he really
needs in my opinion is to go for draw
he has white two more times and he re is
up an entire point so that's kind of his
strategy here but we'll go ahead and
start out the game starts with pawn to a
d4 I can we've kind of seen this all
throughout machine on likes to start
with pawn to d4 and Magnus Carlsen that
pawn to e4 Knight to f6 a pawn here to
c4 pawn here to e6 and the knight here
to f3 and Magnus Carlsen so far has he's
tried to attack this twice in two
different ways one has been the Queen's
Indian defense he's played this pawn to
b6 and he's also played pawn here to d5
kind of the standard mainline Queens
gambit declined lines when he did play
the the pawn here to d5 this is actually
the game that he ended up losing and the
Queen's Indian defenses you know what he
actually ended up time so he's
interesting to see in the game he chose
the Queens gambit declined lined the you
know from earlier he lost this and so
obviously he's probably gonna go for a
different variation so we'll continue
and they play the same moves for a while
so this is they were rapid fire through
this because they had just played these
same variations bishop periods f4 castle
pawn here to e3 and then the first
novelty in the game was pawn here to c5
and the original game that Magnus
Carlsen lost a vision on just a few days
ago we played Knight here to d7 that
didn't work out so well for him and so
he decided for more of a sharper line
with pawn here to c5 main line continues
with the pawn taking here on c5 which
and now the bishop recaptures here on c5
and i like this a little bit better from
magnus carlsen I always like to exchange
get one of your opponent's middle pawns
central pawns off the board and I like
to recapture getting a more aggressive
piece on the board to this bishop here
on c5 is very aggressive controlling
this long diagonal right here which can
be sometimes a weakness for white early
on into the game since this White King
here anyone is really only defending the
square here on f2 so nice little square
definitely a better
I think transition and variation the
Magnus Carlsen went down then that night
here to d7 which just didn't seem like a
normal play style for Magnus Carlsen so
much better start again Vichy Don still
has a slight lead since he is white but
he's definitely not to find some nice
attacking lines or we could just end up
in a draw game we now see pawn to a3
doesn't want to have to deal with this
bishop coming down here to b4 kind of
that nimzo-indian defense where your
opponent has their Bishop here on b4 and
then they try to exchange here and then
give you double pawns on the C file
machine on just doesn't have to deal
with that Knight to c6 developing pieces
a queen here to c2 again just trying to
complete the development here also just
trying to get a little bit more of an
aggressive Queen right here and then a
pretty interesting move for - cross and
it looks you know pretty basic just rook
over here to e8 trying to centralize a
little bit but vision on and the press
conference afterwards said that this
move caught him off guard for IB on our
call Caruana one of the top players in
the world I think maybe he's even the
best player in the world although
obviously he's not the world champion
but I think in a few years he'll
actually be the Challenger playing
whoever is the champion right now but he
actually said that this was kind of an
unnecessary move from Magnus Carlsen it
takes him down some aggressive lines
that Magnus Carlsen doesn't really need
to be playing since he's up the point he
just play for a draw Magnus Carlsen not
one to shy away from aggressive lines
even though it doesn't necessarily look
like an aggressive line it's definitely
not a theoretical move that people play
a lot so fishing on definitely was
expecting something else said he hadn't
really prepared for this move he didn't
think he was
top-level as he said so it was very
interesting so play continues after a
little thinking from Vichy and on he
played Bishop here to g5 pinning this
Knight down to the Queen
now the bishops gonna come back here to
e7 and then we have rook over here to d1
getting it on this semi open square
which is always where you want your
rooks to be we now see Magnus Carlsen
continue with his active play Queen here
to a5 a recognized and it's gonna be
very difficult to go ahead and start to
attack on the King side but on the Queen
side all of a sudden he can pin this
Knight down to the King his opponents
definitely gonna be looking to get his
life square Bishop involved into the
game
maybe castle on the King side for some
safety here but right now this Knights
not gonna be able to move so we see the
bishop come up here to d3 again as we
talked about getting ready to castle on
the King side wants to make sure you can
freely move this Knight around what she
can't do right now pawn here to h6
forcing the bishop to come back and then
pawn taking here on c4 now thought this
was pretty interesting for Magnus
Carlsen I'm not sure that he really
needs to exchange here on c4 giving up
one of his central pawns he did have
some other options you know rook over
here to d8 seems fine Bishop to d7 maybe
just completing his development here
getting his lights for a bishop involved
maybe later instead he wants to bring
his bishop over here on light squares
and control over here but Bishop to d7
seems fine it's definitely better than
it was before and then it can get his
other rook involved if he wants to swing
over here to d8 maybe the semi open file
here on c8 that works as well so pawn
taking here on c4 looked interesting to
see but then the bishop retaking here on
a c4 pawn here to a6 getting ready to
push forward with pawn to b5 and then
again if he wants to he can get his
LightSquared Bishop involved into the
game castle on the King side and then we
see the pawn to b5 as we discussed now
the bishops gonna fall back here to a2
somewhat controlling this long diagonal
right here but both sides have their
pawns here on e3 and E 6 so it does
mitigate some of the risk as far as
mitigating some of the control that his
opponents have for their bishops this
LightSquared Bishop you know
typically controlling this long diagonal
is good but with this pawn here it just
really can't do much same thing with
this dark square it would really like to
control this long diagonal but with this
pawn here on e3 it just doesn't have
much to do here so now we see Bishop to
b7 getting it active involved into the
game controlling this long diagonal
which is going to be pretty good square
for this light super Bishop and then
Bishop over here to b1 threatening this
queen up here to h7 if this Knight is
off the board here on f6 what's
interesting is just seventeen moves into
the game magnus carlsen only used
fifteen minutes now again he's playing
the black pieces so he's defending but
he's defending extremely well and he's
playing very very quick if you've kind
of watched this so far as far as all the
games it is not the fastest game of all
time because again the pressure is so
high they're playing in a World
Championship level any mistake could
cost them the title so for Magnus
Carlsen to play 15 minutes for the first
17 moves his black that is definitely
definitely fast machine on on the other
hand has taken 45 minutes so he's
already behind 30 minutes oh you know
that move rook here to e8 kind of caught
him off guard he definitely wants to
make sure that playing the white pieces
he's optimizing all his moves because he
only has two more games as white so if
he doesn't get a win here it's
definitely going to put him under the
gun and a lot more pressure with the
last four games we now see Magnus
Carlsen bring his rook over here to the
8 just centralizing his rook definitely
what you want to be on this open file
Magnus Carlsen is completely okay just
exchanging off material here again if he
can just race for a draw they would
shake hands right now if they would
allow him to because again he's up a
piece or a entire point here in the
match there's no reason for him to try
to do anything too crazy and so you know
again if the chignon wants to go ahead
and exchange that it's gonna be fine
with Magnus Carlsen the bishop takes
here on f6 and the bishop recaptures
here there's no real need for vision on
to play Queen here to h7 which which he
doesn't you know check the King after
the King moves here to F fades all of a
sudden the attack has kind of blocked we
can't really do too much now maybe you
just continue with Knight here to e4 and
the game just decides to go and play the
Knight to e4 instead
because you know again your Queen over
here on h7 just isn't doing too much now
the bishop it goes back here to e7 and
then centralizing a little bit more for
vision on so this is definitely good
he's trying a little bit to get his
knight involved into the game but it's
very unclear how he's going to continue
there's not a lot of weaknesses from
both sides of the board on the King side
the pawn structures are pretty much
equal on the Queen side the pawn strokes
are pretty much equal both sides have
equal amount of material and there's
just not a lot of critical squares that
either side really controls that they
can really take advantage of we now see
an exchange off the board and then pawn
here to be for this really threatens an
exchange of the Queen's which is what
Magnus Carlsen wants fishing on if you
wanted to you could maybe bring his
Queen back here to see to but that may
just be a little too passive so instead
he decides okay I'm gonna have to
exchange off my queen but first he
brings his rook over here to c1
we now see the pawn take on a3 and then
the Queen's are going to exchange here
on a c5 and this again what Magnus
Carlsen wants to do there's no reason
for him not to try to exchange all the
pieces off the board and try to go for a
quick draw here tonight coming back here
to e7 rook over here to c1 and now we do
see an exchange of the roofs right here
and then we just enter a game with two
minor pieces and some pawns
there's no real way for either side to
win this potentially if it was bishops
on opposite colors maybe you can find a
small advantage but right now there's
just no way for either side to really
gain an advantage here both players are
just too strong and in game to let this
slip away so both sides start to
centralize their Kings a little bits on
the board and they don't play too many
more moves in this Patera game and they
were moving pretty fast all of these are
pretty elementary for this type of
player they centralize a little bit more
and then after this move here of 41 they
decide to go ahead and draw so vision on
I thought he played well I don't think
he put Magnus Carlsen in too many tough
positions Magnus Carlsen pretty much
played
normal magnus carlsen and then he was
able to just exchange off all the
material without again ever putting
himself in much danger of losing
appoints i don't think he ever ever had
a possibility to win himself but i don't
think that's what he was trying for so
congrats to magnus carlsen on the drawl
if I can say that's because he is again
up a point now both players they have a
rest date tomorrow and then they come
back Magnus Carlsen has the white pieces
both players have white pieces twice
more so vision on hopefully on this off
day rest day is going to take some time
to reflect and maybe come up with the
new strategy maybe he doesn't even try D
for next time but hopefully something
that can get back into this I think
would be really cool if we could be tied
up going into one of the last two games
in the series that would definitely make
it exciting instead of just you know
Magnus Carlsen trying to play for a draw
so hopefully you guys enjoyed the series
and hopefully a vision on can make it
interesting in a few more games thanks
for watching I'll see you guys the next
video